do you remember the Discovery Channel
for many of us the Discovery Channel was
a classic portion of our childhood
basically if you had grown out of the
Nickelodeon and Disney phase you were
probably watching the Discovery Channel
they had everything from How It's Made
Gold Rush Cash Cab and a Deadliest Catch
to MythBusters Dirty Jobs planet Earth
ended naked and afraid they also had
random one-off specials like Nick
Wallenda crossing the Grand Canyon also
who could forget shark week every year
Shark Week almost felt like a worldwide
event like the world cup or the Olympics
whether you went to get a haircut or
went to Home Depot you'd probably
overhear people talking about Shark Week
but since then much has changed for the
Discovery Channel for one many people
don't even have regular cable TV or
satellite TV instead it they simply have
a handful of subscriptions like Netflix
and Disney Plus along with Maybe YouTube
premium the Discovery Channel did try to
write this new trend by launching their
own streaming service called The
Discovery Plus in late 2020 but this
hasn't worked out all that well sure
they were able to get about 22 million
subscribers but this isn't nothing in
comparison to their status a decade ago
in 2010 for example MythBusters alone
pulled an 85.8 million views within just
the first nine months of the year the
Discovery Channel was actually so big
that they were their own public company
worth as much as 20 billion dollars but
more recently the Discovery Channel
agreed to complete a merger with Warner
media and this is how their new stock
has performed their popularity graph
isn't much better either in fact it's
actually worse since the 2000s search
volume for the Discovery Channel has
literally dropped by 90 to 95 so here's
the rise and fall of one of the most
classic media businesses of our entire
generation
taking a look back the story of the
Discovery Channel dates all the way back
to 1982 to a man named John Hendricks
John had a pretty average background his
father owned a local contractor business
while his mother worked as a clerk at
the city government so like most people
John's obvious career choice was to go
to college and get a job John ended up
attending the University of Alabama
where he studied history this was also
when John started experimenting with
this creative side you see her while
John attended College he had a part-time
job working in the audio visual
department and this is where he really
fell in love with producing
documentaries John felt that the quality
documentaries were something that the
American public severely lacked but he
also wasn't crazy enough to dive
straight into the media business instead
he got a traditional job at his
university after graduation regulate
community and government relations
he would eventually transition to the
University of Maryland where he did the
same job but this time he would also
work on an entrepreneurial project he
co-founded a fundraising consulting
company that focused on publishing at
academic newsletters the company never
Rose to insane Heights but it looks like
it gave Jon enough confidence to take a
gamble with media so in 1982 John
founded cable educational Network and as
you would guess the company focused on
providing it documentary programming to
Cable broadcasters the big jump forward
didn't come till 1985 though when bigger
players also became interested in the
space the BBC was likely the most well
known of these but they were by no means
the only one these players became
investors in a new project led by Jonah
called it the Discovery Channel
initially this was just supposed to be a
subsidiary of cable educational network
but as funding grew larger and larger
Jon would shift his entire Focus to the
Discovery Channel soon enough he would
actually change the name of the parent
company to discover Communications Inc
and that marked the beginning of the
network that we're all familiar with
today at first the company only
broadcast 12 hours a day between 3 pm
and 3 AM to a modest 156 000 households
but everything they aired was a banger
75 of their content had never been seen
by an American audience and much of it
covered a fascinating educational
content this included cultural
documentaries wallet life documentaries
and Science and History specials as well
they even had some Soviet programming
very early on they also experimented
with shark week which quickly turned
into an annual event given that
Americans couldn't get this content
anywhere else the Discovery Channel
exploded in popularity in fact within
five years of launch their reach would
grow from 156 000 households to 50
million households John had clearly hit
a gold mine and all that was left was to
double down it and to build on this
success
first the next steps were obvious and
clear just keep doing exactly what you
were doing it but at a larger scale this
meant expanding to an international
audience and launching and acquiring new
networks and that this is exactly what
Discovery did they expanded to the UK in
1989 and they followed us up with an
expansion to Asia and Latin America
something you may not know about
Discovery is that they actually owned a
bunch of our other favorite channels as
well this started off with an
acquisition of TLC in 1991 and quickly
grew to Encompass Animal Planet planet
green the Military Channel and the fit
TV Discovery also read a number of
popular websites including how
stuffworks.com and ended pre-hugger.com
while they had their hands in so many
different genres and mediums the core
mission of the company always rang true
which was to be the number one
non-fiction Media Company all of this
climaxed in 2001 when the Discovery
Channel became the world's most widely
distributed television brand they were
even bigger than Netflix's today
reaching 300 million households in over
180 countries at one point it was
estimated that their accumulative
viewers had even crossed one billion
people per year they had made it to the
absolute top but this made the following
question it very difficult to answer
where do they go from here well the
correct answer would have been to just
keep doing what they were doing it and
be happy being a mature media company
but investors nor Executives were
exactly pleased with just that they
wanted more growth more viewers and of
course more money and the given that
Discovery had peaked out in the
non-fiction Market there was only one
way to continue growing aim for a
broader audience this meant adding in
more elements of reality TV and focusing
more on the storyline than the actual
facts in the beginning this actually
worked out great in fact you could even
argue that this is exactly what
Discovery was previously missing while
purely non additional content was great
this extra element made the content
phenomenal and this gave rise to the
Golden Age of discovery shows like
MythBusters Dirty Jobs and the Deadliest
Catch had this perfect mix of
non-fiction and a fiction MythBusters
for example centered on the scientific
process physics and Engineering but it
wasn't limited to just that it also had
its personalities drama emotions and
most importantly people that you could
relate with Mike Rowe from Dirty Jobs
was likely one of the most down-to-earth
people to have ever been on TV this
golden period it didn't last forever
though in late 2007 Discovery announced
that they were gonna go public in 2008.
this was terrible timing given that it
was during the heart of the Great
Recession and it wasn't that surprising
that the IPO didn't go all that well but
this lackluster IPO was just the
beginning of discovery's long and
painful descent
foreign
now that Discovery was public pressure
from investors was larger than ever and
they were legally obligated to act in
the best interest of investors Discovery
was already headed in the direction of
adding in too much reality and in not
enough science but the IPO is simply
solidified this trend this showed that
most people point to it as being the
epitome of discovery's decline is
American Chopper the show focused on a
group of people who set out to create
the world's most unique motorcycles
while this was indeed an interesting
premise it added virtually nothing to do
with Science Education or learning it
was a reality show a successful one yes
but was it something that aligned with
discovery's Mission not at all while the
show garnered a bunch of viewers it was
a completely different demographic
fortunately classic Discovery viewers
had classic shows to turn back to right
well yes and no the classic shows were
indeed still being produced and aired
but these two were missing something
Shark Week for example started receiving
a bunch of criticism that it was filled
with a bunch of misinformation and the
blatantly false science similarly
MythBusters was drifting away from
science and experiments to action and
explosions we saw fewer clips of Jaime
or Grant explaining Newton's laws and
the more clips of the crew blowing up
random crap just for fun now don't get
me wrong here watching them blow up
random crap was quite entertaining in
itself but at the same time you couldn't
deny that the show had somehow lost what
made it so great soon enough these shows
weren't just losing their souls but they
were getting canceled the this didn't
necessarily mean that the shows were
doing bad per se but they had simply
reached their natural ends dirty jobs
for example wrapped up in 2012 while
MythBusters wrapped up in 2016. usually
there would have been plenty of shows
that these viewers could have switched
to but this time up all that was left
was the ubiati crap and over time the
core Discovery viewers simply tuned out
this downtrend was simply accelerated by
macro conditions within the media
industry the trender wasn't to get cable
or satellite TV the trend was the ditch
cable and satellite TV in 2015 76 of
Americans had traditional TV but by 2021
only 56 of Americans had traditional TV
meanwhile platforms like Netflix and
Hulu were skyrocketing in popularity
Netflix for example has grown from 50
million subscribers to over 200 million
subscribers in the last seven to eight
years and the worst part about all of
this was that the majority of people
leaving cable for Netflix was the more
generic audience who was interested in
the reality shows meanwhile the people
that were left behind were the classic
Discovery viewers yet Discovery was
spending all of their efforts chasing it
after the rapidly shrinking reality
audience and at this point there was
only one way that the story could end
looking forward while Discovery is by no
means as large as they once used to be
there's still a sizable media
organization I mean 22 million
subscribers is nothing to scoff at also
the merger with Warner media has boosted
their total subscribers all the way to
over 90 million with this new Catalyst
it seems like it's just a matter of time
until the new discovery is able to
arrive on Netflix and Disney with their
200 million plus subscriber counts but
while Discovery has a solid chance to
become a media giant once again to
Discovery that we all knew and loved it
is though very much dead the second wave
of growth will almost completely be
fueled by reality shows like Trixie
Motel 90 Day Fiance alone and Ghost
Adventures and given the merger with
Warner media it's unlikely that
Discovery will ever return to what we
remember it as they've simply shifted to
serving the broader entertainment market
and that's what happened to Discovery do
you guys prefer the older Discovery or
the new discovery coming that down below
also drop a like if you missed deal or
Discovery and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggest activity ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one